Though he may not be at his most recognizable
in his role in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
2, the actor who plays Tullk in the Marvel
sequel is bound to look familiar to any avid
moviegoer.
His name is Tommy Flanagan, an actor with
a mile-long resume and a pair of distinctive
scars.
He's one of those actors whose name you can't
quite remember, but whose face you know by
heart.
Here are a few flicks you might have seen
him in.
​Braveheart
Flanagan is an extraordinarily Scottish man,
so it should come as no surprise that his
first big break was in 1995's Braveheart,
the epic historical drama directed by and
starring Mel Gibson.
Flanagan played a villager named Morrison
whose wedding is interrupted by the repulsive
Lord Bottoms, who steals Morrison's bride
for the night.
Happily, Morrison gets his revenge when he
joins WIlliam Wallace's army...
"It was my right!"
"Your right?
Well I'm here to claim the right of a husband!"
The Saint
This 1997 thriller cashed in on the then-solid
superstar status of Val Kilmer, who was coming
off his one-movie stint as Batman and still
sporting an action-hero's physique, perfect
for his role in The Saint.
Kilmer plays the lead role, a smarmy thief-for-hire
with the world's most ridiculous collection
of disguises ...
"It's so early.
You guys want to get some coffee or something?"
Of course, the billionaire Russian oligarch
who enlists the Saint also needs a couple
of loyal henchmen to help with his schemes
— enter Flanagan, who joined the cast as
a thug known as Scarface.
For the most part, his role consists of hovering
nearby and looking intimidating.
Flanagan was apparently not a fan of the movie's
leading man.
In 2004, he "slowly and precisely" said this
into one journalist's tape recorder: "Val
Kilmer's a prick."
Face/Off
Not content to play just one role per year
as the right-hand man to a movie villain,
in 1997 Flanagan also showed up in John Woo's
brilliant — and brilliantly absurd — Face/Off,
a film that was a giant hit at the box office,
despite its repulsive and ridiculous premise.
Flanagan plays a Leo, a henchman to the evil
Castor Troy, a role played by both Nicolas
Cage and John Travolta...you know, because
of the face-swapping thing.
“I’d like to take his… his face… off.”
Flanagan turns up in multiple scenes as a
strong, silent member of the villain's support
staff, where he's easily identifiable as a
Bad Guy thanks to his stylishly sleazy turtleneck-and-blazer
combo.
The Game
1997 was a big year for Flanagan.
After playing a couple of toughs in The Saint
and Face/Off, he also had a memorable turn
as a crazy cabbie in The Game.
A twisted David Fincher thriller, Michael
Douglas starred as a cold-hearted businessman
who ends up fighting for his life on his forty-eighth
birthday in an elaborate role-playing game...gone
mad!
Flanagan is on camera in this for only about
fifteen seconds, and has zero lines, but his
performance makes a big impression.
Gladiator
With one historical epic already under his
belt, Flanagan scored an even bigger part
in his next one in 2000: Ridley Scott's Gladiator,
where he played Maximus' loyal servant Cicero.
It was one of the actor's most significant
cinematic roles yet, and really showed off
his range.
Not only did Flanagan demonstrate that he
makes a totally convincing good guy, complete
with a noble and dramatic on screen death
...
"I'm sorry."
… but he also toned down his thick accent
considerably ...
"I do what I have to."
​Charlie's Angels: Full Throttle
Hollywood's always in need of a few good bad
guys.
And by 2003, Flanagan was high on the list
of the industry's most eligible henchmen.
"Lights!
Somebody got the lights!"
His nameless roughhouser in ​Charlie's Angels:
Full Throttle, credited only as "Irish Henchman,"
was part of the squad assembled by the evil
Irishmen Seamus O'Grady.
Flanagan took plenty of licks from the ladies,
but says Lucy Lui was the hardest-hitting
Angel in the trio.
Sin City
Flanagan next turned up in Robert Rodriguez's
gruesome 2005 film Sin City.
There, he played a mercenary named Brian in
a vignette titled "The Big Fat Kill," where
he memorably chucks a grenade at a mute assassin
...
"Suck on this, you stupid slag!"
… and then makes an elegant escape down
a manhole with Benicio del Toro's severed
head — surely a career highlight.
When a Stranger Calls
This 2006 remake of the classic horror film
features Flanagan as the namesake stranger,
who terrorizes a hapless babysitter with a
series of threatening phone calls.
Although Flanagan doesn't actually speak in
When a Stranger Calls — the creepy voice
on the line belongs to actor Lance Henriksen
from the Alien series — the image of him
in the back of a police car in the film's
final moments make it clear why he was a perfect
casting choice.
​Sons of Anarchy
Flanagan's is best-known role is also the
one he played the longest, as fan favorite
"Chibs" Telford on the FX series Sons of Anarchy.
"Jackie boy, this place is fantastic!"
"I'm so excited."
The show tells the story of a gun-running
motorcycle gang that may or may not be loosely
based on the famous Hell's Angels.
Flanagan played Telford for all seven seasons,
as he rose in the ranks to become Sergeant-at-Arms,
Vice President, and finally President Motorcycle
Guy.
Nice guys don't always finish last!
​There's more ...
Still don't know where you've seen Flanagan?
Over the years, you may have spotted him on
one of several high-profile prime time properties,
including Revenge, Gotham, and a memorable
turn as a loan shark on Law & Order: SVU,
in which he actually has the gall to threaten
Ice-T ....
"Tell your girlfriend she's gonna be sorry."
"Threatening a detective, huh?
Why don't we add that to the rest of your
charges?"
Going toe to toe with Ice T?
That's pretty...cool.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!